23 cm de diamètre,
4 cm d'épaisseur.
1,8kg. Question taille, c'est sûr,
c'est bien un Saint-Nectaire réglementaire.
Pour la couleur, tous les voyants sont au vert.
Enfin ce que je veux dire,
c'est que la croûte grise orangée
parsemée de moisissures
correspond parfaitement aux standards.
Et je ne vous parle pas du parfum.
Là, je suis sûr que
je vous donne envie.
Envie d'en savoir plus, évidemment
sur le Saint-Nectaire,
vous allez voir qu'il en a
dans la "tranche" ce fromage.
Le Saint-Nectaire est un fromage produit
en Auvergne,
au cœur du Massif central.
Enfin, pas partout en Auvergne,
uniquement dans ce petit secteur
à cheval sur les départements
du Cantal et du Puy de Dôme.
Sa zone de production s'étend sur
seulement 1.800 kilomètres carrés.
C'est l'une des plus petites
pour un fromage français
détenant une appellation
d'origine contrôlée.
A titre de comparaison,
celle du brie de Meaux
est presque dix fois plus grande.
Et à quoi ça ressemble,
le pays du Saint-Nectaire ?
Un paysage de petites montagnes
qui s'échelonnent entre 800
et 1500 mètres d'altitude.
Les vaches pèsent sur les pentes
d'anciens volcans émoussés par le temps
qui changent de couleur au gré
des saisons et des floraisons.
Elles ont vu sur le Puy de Sancy,
le Puy Gros ou encore le Puy Ferrand.
Il y a pire comme bureau.
C'est sûr !
C'est pas laid,
enfin, je veux dire,
c'est pas moche.
Le Saint-Nectaire est fabriqué
à partir du lait de vaches
qui doivent obligatoirement
être nées et être élevées
sur l'une des 69 communes
de la zone d'appellation.
Peu importe la race.
Cependant, une vache sort du lot :
La Montbéliarde.
Son lait, est réputé pour faire
de bons fromages.
Il est d'ailleurs utilisé  pour la fabrication du Comté,
du Cantal ou encore du Morbier.
Ces vaches doivent en outre passer
au minimum 160 jours par an dans les pâturages,
avec au menu ...
direction la cuisine !
De la Knautie d’Auvergne,
de la flouve odorante.
De loin, ça ressemble un petit peu à du blé,
du thym serpolet, de l'achillée millefeuille.
Mais on trouve également  de l'anthrisque, du gaillet
croisette, du fenouil des Alpes
et sur les hauteurs de la gentiane.
Tu te régales, hein ?
C’est pas ici qu’elles trouveraient leur bonheur, hein.
Et lorsque le froid arrive,
elle rentre à l'étable et continue à se nourrir
essentiellement de foin
100% naturel et 100% local.
Un peu de compléments alimentaires,
mais très surveillé, aucun aliment OGM.
Allez, un peu d'histoire maintenant.
Le Saint-Nectaire  détient une appellation d'origine
protégée depuis 1955.
A l'époque, on parlait d'AOC.
C'est assez récent
comparé à d'autres fromages.
Et pourtant, ces racines
sont très anciennes.
Déjà, au moment de
l'invasion romaine,
le peuple Arvernes,
qui vivait dans la région,
était réputé pour la qualité
de ses fromages.
Au Moyen-Âge, les paysans du coin
payaient leurs impôts avec du fromage
dit de seigle, baptisé
ainsi car à l'époque,
il était affiné sur
de la paille de seigle.
Mais ce n'est que durant
la deuxième moitié du 17e siècle
que ce fromage franchit
les frontières de l'Auvergne.
Le maréchal Henri de La Ferté-Sennecterre,
le fait découvrir à Louis XIV.
Le roi tombe sous le charme.
Et quand le roi aime, le succès est garanti.
Selon les spécialistes,  le nom de ce maréchal
serait vraisemblablement
à l'origine de celui du fromage.
Sennecterre, Saint-Nectaire.
C'est vrai que ça
sonne un peu pareil.
Et le village de
Saint-Nectaire, alors?
Il compte pour du beurre?
Peut-être pas. C'est
une autre hypothèse.
Selon certains, des touristes
en cure thermale à Saint-Nectaire
auraient donné le nom de la commune
au fromage local
qu'ils consommaient
et qu'ils rapportaient dans leurs valises.
On ne sait pas tout ce qui se cache
sous la croûte de ce fromage.
C'est ça qui fait son charme.
Enfin, le charme du Saint-Nectaire,
c'est surtout son goût.
Ce n'est pas pour rien
qu'il est inscrit
à l'inventaire du patrimoine
culturel immatériel de la France.
Le Saint-Nectaire est un fromage
à pâte pressée non cuite.
Après la traite on ajoute de la présure
dans le lait pour le faire caillé,
un peu comme on le fait
pour les yaourt.
Sous l'effet de la présure,
les protéines et la matière grasse
coagulent et forment un gel
qu'on appelle le caillé.
Ce caillé est ensuite découpé.
Un liquide remonte à la surface.
C'est le lactosérum,
on dit aussi "le petit lait".
Autrement dit,
de l'eau et du lactose,
l'élément que certaines personnes
ont du mal à digérer dans le lait.
Au passage, il est
là, le génie du fromage.
Une opération qui, à l'origine,
a permis de séparer
les différents composants du lait,
d'écarter l'eau et le sucre, le glucose,
empêchant ainsi  le développement de certains micro-organismes
tout en permettant de conserver
les nutriments contenus dans le lait.
Le caillé est ensuite transvasé dans des moules dont le
fond est percé comme une passoire.
Puis, il est pressé
pendant plusieurs heures.
Voilà pourquoi on parle d'un
fromage à pâte pressée non cuite.
Ensuite, il est salé et enfin,
c'est l'affinage qui dure 28 jours minimum.
Il faut 14 litres de lait  pour fabriquer un
Saint-Nectaire comme celui-ci.
Et quand on coupe un morceau,
on voit bien que la pâte n'a pas été cuite.
Elle est souple, à la différence
de celle d'un Salers, par exemple, qui est dure.
Saint-Nectaire ici,
Saint-Nectaire là.
C'est quoi la différence ?
Suis-moi, je t'explique.
D'abord, le Saint-Nectaire doit faire
entre 20 et 24 cm de diamètre.
De 3,5 à 5,5 cm d'épaisseur
et son poids doit être compris
entre 1,450 kg et 1,950 kg.
Ensuite, il en existe deux types.
Le fermier, d'abord élaboré à la ferme
comme son nom l'indique,
avec du lait provenant d'un seul et même
troupeau et du lait cru,
c'est à dire du lait qui n'a
pas subi de traitement thermique.
Comme le lait vient de la même
ferme que c'est un produit vivant.
Chaque production de Saint-Nectaire
fermier peut avoir un goût
légèrement différent et qui varie
aussi en fonction des saisons.
Celui-ci a un petit goût de noisette.
Celui-ci a un petit goût de sous bois.
Mais comme on les reconnaît ?
Faut goûter avant d’acheter ?
Non, il faut bien regarder.
La croûte d'abord grise, orangée
avec des moisissures.
Mais pas seulement, tout Saint-Nectaire
fermier doit posséder une plaque
comme celle-ci.
Pour la trouver, il faut parfois un peu
gratter sur celui-ci.
Elle se trouve là, hop !
Une plaque ovale de couleur
verte et en caséine.
La caséine étant une protéine
contenue dans le lait.
C''est sa carte d'identité.
Et l'autre, alors, c'est quoi?
C'est ce qu'on appelle
un Saint-Nectaire laitier.
Sa croûte est beaucoup plus claire.
Ce fromage est fabriqué
dans l'une des quatre laiteries de l'AOP Saint-Nectaire,
avec des laits provenant
de plusieurs exploitations.
Il est d'abord chauffé
pendant quelques minutes
à une température
d'environ 75 degrés.
On dit qu'il est pasteurisé
de Pasteur, l'inventeur du vaccin.
C'est le processus qui permet de supprimer
une partie des micro-organismes.
Il est un peu plus doux que le fermier,
il a un petit goût de beurre ou de crème.
Ce fromage possède sa propre plaque
d'immatriculation.
Ici, sous la croûte.
Elle est carrée et non plus ovale
et de couleur blanche.
Personnellement, j'ai une petite
préférence pour celui-ci.
Le Saint-Nectaire fermier
et je mange même la croûte.
Mais comme on dit,
les goûts et les couleurs.
Et vous ? Lequel préférez-vous ?
Dites-le-moi en commentaire.
Faites-en tout un fromage
si vous en avez envie et régalez-vous.
Et si vous aimez les Épicurieux,
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner.
Allez à très bientôt !